there are new questions being raised
about one of the methods used to
encourage vaccines during the pandemic
some states use taxpayer money to fund
vaccine lotteries in West Virginia which
had one of the largest sweepstakes
anyone who got that coveted shot could
register for cash and prizes but now
there is scrutiny over whether the money
was wasted and if the programs actually
worked Scott McFarland has the story
this was the moment now I'm really
nervous Grace Fowler a medical worker
trying to help her community Through
covid received what she thought was a
wonderful surprise all of a sudden
there's cameras is the governor yeah in
a photo op yes
it was exciting wow I'd won a truck you
know yeah wait what
no I didn't she was one of the hundreds
of winners who entered West Virginia's
do it for baby dog vaccine sweepstakes
run by the state's colorful Governor Jim
Justice you've got to get for baby doll
West Virginia's vaccine Lottery was
massive more than 20 million dollars in
prizes larger than lotteries in
neighboring Ohio and Maryland combined
and named after Justice's pet dog with
scholarships vacations cash a million
588 thousand dollars what and trucks CBS
News has learned Federal investigators
have subpoenaed Governor Justice's
office about the sweepstakes the focus
according to the governor's staff are
those trucks and questions about how
much they cost taxpayers
only after Fowler brought home a prize
did she learn the value may have been
inflated and along with it her tax bill
what was your reaction when they sent
you a bill for twenty thousand dollars
plus for your truck come on I was like
okay so I said the next time someone
says you win I'm gonna say keep it the
lottery has also triggered a political
battle at home where the Republican
governor recently launched a bid for U.S
Senate one of Justice's critics a state
auditor who reviewed spending for the
lottery says it was hastily executed and
rushed taxpayer money out the door to
private businesses it's very very hard
for me to manage in really quick short
time frames is this okay is this legal
where is this going what was the
contract where's the documentation where
are the dates right Republican state
senator Eric Tarr a political rival of
the governor said the tens of millions
of federal dollars spent by Governor
Justice for incentives missed the mark
did the vaccine Lottery help
boost the vaccination rate no I don't
believe it did if you're going to spend
21 million dollars to improve
vaccination rate you would expect to see
a little bump if it was something that
was going to be an effective plan it's a
little too ambitious it's way too
ambitious for something that really had
no reason to know that it was going to
move the needle and it didn't move the
needle Justice declined our request for
an interview his team says they
responded to Federal investigators with
records when they were subpoenaed as for
Grace Fowler she parted ways with her
prize the year after winning it just one
like
for years and years and years so I
decided Well let's just sell the truck
pay the taxes
be done with it
the car dealer that supplied and Grace
Fowler's prize declined CBS News
requests for comment on this but they
submitted documents claiming that truck
was loaded with extras raising its value
the governor's office acknowledged Gail
Grace Fowler wasn't the only winner to
sell the winning prize yep those extra
Scott will get you every time it reminds
me you know when you're a little kid and
your mom says if something is too good
to be true it probably is
so we just heard that the governor's
critics said listen the lottery didn't
lead to enough vaccinations what more
can you tell us about that there are
multiple studies including those
published in the Journal of the American
Medical Association which say there's
little evidence vaccine lotteries led to
higher vaccine rates but the governor's
office said this Lottery helped command
The public's attention in a vaccine
hesitant state so that he could educate
about the safety and efficacy of
vaccines but Vlad we're at this point
now three years three months after covet
arrived where there are critical
questions about how money was spent so
much money in such a short period of
time
yeah and your heart just goes out to
people like that who are like you know
next time I hear that I've won something
I'm just going to tell them to keep it
uh Scott thank you very much for that
reporting appreciate it but you know
what in those early days we didn't
really know what we were dealing with
everybody should we get the shot should
we not get the shot oh I'll get a truck
or I'll get money if I get the shot
maybe I'll get it enticing yes yeah a
lot of Governors were trying to entice
people get those shots